[Music]  hey check it out we're here welcome to  key house I could never get your father  to talk about his life here my kids need  a home does it have to be this one yes  James is filled with amazing keys  for them  they whisper you heard that  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  holy crap  I knew this possible  [Music]  this isn't a game we don't know what  these Keys unlock  meeow meeow you have no idea what's  coming  there is a crazy evil thing who wants  these keys  [Music]  these aren't toys the weapons  these keys  there are legacy  there's something that connects us with  dad  the past is always with us  you're gonna try it on way  it's always there whatever you think you  understand about those keys you don't  [Music]  you  [Music]  you